[Musique]
le marché pays du département a fait son
grand retour au jardin de l'état ce
jeudi 13 août
compte tenu du pic de production
actuelle les agriculteurs ont donc
sollicité le département pour mettre en
place ce marché ils étaient une
quinzaine dans le jardin ce jour ben en
ce moment on se trouve dans une période
où il ya beaucoup de légumes qui reste
un petit aller dans les champs
faute de d'écoulement dont qui permet à
peu de relancer le redynamiser un peu le
le travail et avoir un écoulement direct
avec les consommateurs
tout le monde y connaissent maintenant
parce que ça a été ça a été fait depuis
x temps on avait continué dans le fond
l'arrivée à saint denis tout le monde
connaît tout le monde me pose la même
question quand c'est que vous allez
refaire le marché pays par les gens nous
réclament à fond on adore travailler on
adore retrouver les gens on adore
retrouver nos clients et ils sont super
heureux ce matin c'est au moins me
retrouve ma clientèle afflue hantaient
le syllabus en effet de plantain et
retrouve ainsi que les habitudes alors
voilà des produits de qualité en vente
directe auprès des agriculteurs une
initiative très appréciée des
consommateurs
faussement comme s'il fait très bon
c'est très beau cadre
je crois qu'on a choisi le moment est
idéal tel endroit l'emplacement idéal
pour eux accueillir tous les
agriculteurs de la région
c'est une initiative qu'il faudrait
renouveler à disons qu'on a le contact
avec la personne qui justement qu'il
passe son temps à nous à nous faire
vivre et puis que eux ils ont ils
rencontrent des difficultés donc à la
limite ça serait un bon échange de
posséder de les aider des gars des vues
et puis nous de pouvoir manger ça ne
ment voilà l'occasion également de
découvrir des fruits rares méconnues ou
oubliées tels que le chic ou le chipeau
c'est pas un fait nouveau un c'est un
fruit il fait partie de la famille
depuis longtemps il a été introduit à la
réunion dans les années 1800 1850 1170
pas là mais c'est un fou il a jamais été
développé et non le but c'est justement
de pouvoir développer ses fruits l'an et
que demain on puisse les trouver sur les
étages puisque les gens puissent être
précis alors c'est un fruit avec la
texture de
de leur foi et sucré donc on ne va pas
là lui leur quoi au caramel un retour
gagnant pour ce marché pays qui démontre
encore que le département soutient le
monde agricole et la production locale
[Musique]